people of the internet's retro reckons
who are here hello and welcome back to
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
we
just got finished doing a duel in the
great hall which i completely did not
know about uh so now we are getting
ready to head back into the entrance
hall i'm gonna see if i can find a
prefect badge it's one of the lost items
uh and then after that we're gonna go to
our first care of magical creatures
lesson with hagrid which should be
buckbeak but we'll find out
so i hope everybody is having a
wonderful week so far
and i am looking forward to playing a
little bit more of prisoner of azkaban
here
if you've been enjoying this series
thank you guys so much make sure you hit
that like button before you go it really
helps other people to find the video
and as always you can leave a comment
down below as well let me know what you
think about
what you think about prisoner of azkaban
and and how much
you enjoyed it what are some of your
favorite memories of it because
i thought i played it as a kid but the
more i've been
as i've been doing this let's play there
is so much that i don't remember so i
actually don't know that i played this
one or if i did it was just like a
rental or something that i i definitely
did not finish so a lot of this i'm
experiencing for the first time and i'm
liking it so far
but i do feel like there's a poor
execution a lot of times i feel like
they have some really good ideas
and so we know there should be a prefect
badge hidden
somewhere
now see look at that how the little
curtain there is kind of rippling
there's supposed to be a prefect badge
in the entrance hall somewhere
and that's really all the information
that
we've been given
and so i'm looking all around here and i
just don't see like if they're like they
were in chamber of secrets you really
don't have to do anything super special
to find them you just kind of walk up on
them and they're sort of bouncing they
make it very obvious where they are
maybe we have to talk to somebody i
didn't even think about that
let's talk to this dude right here the
hourglass is showing there it is house
point totals there it is dude let's go
outside look at that right behind
wait the hufflepuff
counter
there we go nicely done
i thought i just walked back there too
return to the prefect badge uh returned
the prefect badge to the notice board
for more house points all right we'll
definitely do that
but now that we found that let's go
ahead and head outside for cara magical
creatures
alright so we are outside and i don't
think i've been here before i definitely
do not remember the clock like that
so we need to make our way down to
hagrid's hut i believe now this is
really cool this little courtyard area
uh i remember this was featured
prominently in the order of the phoenix
video game
but i didn't realize they included it in
this one either man the frame rate the
frame rate is really rough i'm playing
the gamecube version uh actually running
it on the wii so
um makes it look a little bit better
because you can get that progressive
scan with the uh
with the i actually have an hdmi little
converter for the for the wii um but
remember the gamecube i don't know for
for those of you out there who remember
the old school gamecube man the
component cables were notoriously
difficult to find like
and that's how you got the 480p the
progressive scan which certainly nowhere
near hd but made it look a lot better
than the standard and i have no idea
where i'm supposed to go ron and
hermione are just just gone
as harry runs along the hogwarts grounds
here with just like now see i'm not used
to oh there we go there's hagrid's hut
i'm like i'm not used to this because in
chamber of secrets the loading just kind
of jumps around
all right here we go
why does he look so short
now the first thing that got unknown so
short
is there proud oh malfoy's out here too
so to make the phone how this is going
it's polite see
you walk towards him and you bow and you
wait if he bows back you're allowed to
touch him
harry ron hermione who wants to go first
and they all step back
leaving harry
oh my goodness here we go dude he's
right there all right i'm gonna walk up
slowly
now i wait for him to bow right or am i
supposed to walk up and press
oh okay
nice
buck beaks waiting for you to climb on
his back go on oh my goodness
oh my goodness let's go dude well done i
suspect you'd like to fly him let's go
wait wait catch as many as you can catch
as many as you can for those bats a bit
of a run before we can get airborne then
just fly at the back why it's a bad
speaker
bit of a run to get airborne all right
all right you gonna give me the controls
for it or no
nope no controls at all
no controls at all
there isn't enough room to dismount move
to a more open space
there they are jump
what
oh wait what just happened
what's your staff i don't know what made
him jump i think it might be uh b
yeah it's b you gotta press b
oh
man the flight controls
man these flight controls
okay so tilt up there we go there we go
dude oh do i have to keep holding b down
i think i have to hold b
i thought you just had to kind of like
tap it to get him to
did he get some oh he got 12.
all right at least we still got what a
minute and a half roughly
and we need to catch 12 more or is that
how many we've caught so far
i think it started at 20.
okay i guess we totally missed some
right there
whoops
this is kind of cool though it's kind of
cool
he only got one right there are you
serious
oh no
come on buckwheat you got to do better
than that
but where'd they go there they are right
here right here right here
are you serious one each time
dude that is terrible
how did i get did i get like eight the
first time
[Music]
oh no
no come on get back up there
let's go dude
okay knocked it down to nine there's no
way we're getting all of them but
i don't know if you actually have to or
if this is kind of just like
the game giving you
some sort of little fun objective here
while you
well you kind of get used to these
flight controls because i'm assuming
we're gonna need to use these at least
one more time at the very end of the
game
maybe more i don't know but i would
think that would be the only other time
when we uh
spoilers for prisoner of azkaban
oh whoa we got a lot that time knocked
it down to just two all right can we get
two in this last run through we're
probably only gonna have time for one
more run is this it
oh we missed them both no
watch us have to do the whole thing over
again
is that just an acceptable or is that
like an american degrading system eh it
would work
give me a go at that thing
oh here we go you're not dangerous at
all are you you ugly great brute vote no
right in the face
you're not dying it's just a scratch
oh dude
oh wait what which okay
apparently there's a quidditch match now
as the gryffindor team struggled against
the weather
not actually playing the sight of a
giant black dog high in the stands
an eerie silence fell across the stadium
and a horribly familiar way
[Music]
he could hear voices whispering but they
made no sense whatsoever
no sense at all
hey it was a brian
quiet
i know where sirius black is he's down
in the dungeons what
say what
follow me
what
ron
is this like a dream sequence or
something that's so random oh i'm loving
harry's uh night attire though
that is awesome
ron just shows up and he's like i need
to stop run
they haven't even mentioned like like
they've not mentioned trying to go after
sirius black in the game at all
so harry just has this horrible
traumatic thing and ron's like
i found him no
all right let's go harry we gotta help
ron out here
see i don't like that you can't just
like i'm actually hitting him
but it won't let me just
hit multiple shots
so what they're wanting you to do is
wait
is wait for him to throw get me out of
here see that doesn't happen
oh what dodged it just got lucky right
there no i want to lock on to peace
lock on dodge which i didn't do
and then fire and then you can hit him
that's when he's vulnerable
for that little split second there
all right get ready here we come
cool dude i pressed it that time come on
even if he just absolutely drills me
again
okay got it dodged that time got the
lock on
and he's done
take you out peeves
there we go he'll run out of the mud how
serious black he's in the dungeons come
on what
what are you doing ron
he's in the dungeons come on
wait where did he go did he go this way
study area
oh what's going on in here
why is ron acting so weird
this is strange man
whoa
the books are after me
where did ron go anyway dude
was it over here yeah i think it was
this door
back to the grand staircase we go he
said he's going to the dungeons
something is so weird
there's no way he would just completely
leave harry like that
and just keep running like follow me
palta
back to the entrance hall okay
i still never got to report back to the
notice board either that we found that
prefect badge
there he goes again like showing him
vanish as you
get close to him
i really should go ahead and do that too
because
it just increases the likelihood that
you're gonna already
go to a place where you could be looking
for it anyway
all right into the dungeons we go
cutscene time
fran what are you doing we can't take on
serious black on our own
thank you harry
come on
what dude what is this man
avoid being
seen the mechanics of that are so weird
oh yeah i see we have to do now
we have to go
right here
oh wait potions classroom is that where
we go
i don't think so
i do wonder if i could even go in there
though like i'm really
really curious to see who left me
all right is there one more over there
no okay that's it
look
we've got to get professor dumbledore oh
you shut up he's in the corner go on
what
dude this is definitely a dream sequence
right
apologies potion
i think we're even now
perhaps i might mention that i saw
sirius black drag you off what the heck
dude
good night
ron
how did you know where i was
peeves he couldn't wait to tell someone
what draco was up to
i thought he's gonna say he found the
map i brought your stuff including the
marauders map
you couldn't just look at that to find
me oh my goodness
well that was certainly a random little
sequence that
i did not expect okay now we oh wait i
probably have to switch
out
dude what are these little things
[Music]
dude what are these things little
goblins
out of my way dude
can i just run past them
dude come on that was a direct hit and
it just kind of stunned them for a
minute
wow they're everywhere yeah i don't know
if the game actually wants you to try it
wait are we supposed to drop down here
yeah i think we are
yeah yeah yeah drop down let's go
let's go
visit us
yeah where the heck are we man
it's still making the noise like they're
they're nearby
can we call hedwig right here
harry probably has to do it right
oh come on
what
you have to be right in front of it i
guess
here she comes
get us out of here hedwig
please
hello
nothing okay that's it she's just here
now
oh we gotta find a treat right yeah all
right there's a wizard card
[Music]
it's another thing kind of annoying
about the wizard cards is it doesn't if
i remember right there's no
immediate way to see
exactly which one you got
so you have to like go in here and then
you have to know like you just have to
know
i don't think we had a vampires one yet
like it should at least have some sort
of little highlight on it
sir herbert varney 1858 to 1889 hey
late 1800s there we go short-lived by
undead standards victorian vampire who
preyed upon women in london during the
1880s was subsequently captured and
killed by a special squad from the
department for the regulation and
control of magical creatures now you
talk about an awesome
incredible
uh side story in hogwarts legacy man
could you imagine
could you imagine if we're like part of
the special squad
that can uh hunt him down that is insane
he better at least be mentioned right i
mean if it's if the game is late 1800s
he almost has to be mentioned if if
they're talking about him
preying upon women in london during the
1880s
i feel like he would at least have to
warrant a mention in hogwarts legacy
otherwise it wouldn't feel like they had
uh
adequately studied up on all the
research and i feel like i remember
reading this one from chamber of secrets
as well when we did the let's play on
that game or maybe it was sorcerer stone
i don't know but we definitely
i i have read that one before maybe it
was just online on my own doing research
but
yeah i would i would love to see that be
a a storyline at some point in hogwarts
legacy
at least a mention of it i feel like
it's got to be mentioned all right let's
see is this gonna be one of the owl
treats good there we go perfect
all right now let's go back over to
hedwig now that we've got the owl treat
feed hedwig here you go
let's see if this helps us get out of
here oh fetch hermione
betcha
oh wait what i'm supposed to fly
where is hermione
well it's the same controls as as
buckbeak
press and hold b to fly
okay apparently you can't go up that way
go up the stairs
oh you want to go back the way we came
not that way
oh my goodness dude
wait is that ron how'd ron get over here
so wait we're gonna fly back like over
malfoy
okay
dude it's gonna be hilarious if it makes
me fly all the way back to to the
gryffindor common room
like are we gonna have to wait for
loading screens here
nope okay cutscene
and just how about we cut to it there
and then she comes back please
okay there we go i was about to say
i think someone does not make me fly
through the whole castle
these wonky controls
what on earth okay there we go hurry you
should still be in the hospital wing uh
yeah he should long story and one that
involves malfoy and polly juice potion
i feel like the game's just completely
off the rails at this point
i don't know why they felt the need to
add something like this into the game
they're like let's just have
after the quidditch match malfoy's gonna
lure harry
down into the into the dungeons let's
make sure we got everything over here
yeah see there's there's way less
interactive items
i feel like in this game than in uh
chamber of secrets
all right let's head back this way
okay so what was the purpose of hermione
is she like not gonna help us with a
specific spell or something can you
squeeze under the door okay there we go
i was like
could we not have done this on our own
oh wait do i have to actually switch to
her yes i do and she could crawl under
all right now what do we do i think
we've got to get to that switch
can i just press that switch
what is that what does that actually do
why is it locking on
that little bit of parchment right there
oh that's just that's expelliarmus not
gonna help me right here
it all so it always goes back to a
default
shoe spells
lupindo and
uh expelliarmus
yeah yeah we see it we see it
now the question is will all of these
eventually come back or not
and is this even the way we're supposed
to go i'm just taking a guess because
the other path looked like it was broken
with the bridge
maybe she's gonna learn like a rapero
spell or something okay good they don't
come back so that's nice
and why do why do i not have flapindo
and only one bean per cauldron man how
about that
right
who is that oh it's more of those things
are you serious
oh no no no
okay there we go that one's down
they have to actually take them all down
probably dude right
i think it's two hits to knock them down
no no no wait it's locked on right there
what happens if i freeze the water what
does that do
oh she can climb up now i was like
what's the point of the freezing water
there we go two hits on him
let's freeze this one
okay apparently i'm too close for the
spell to work
all right it's gotta be frozen right
one more but here from those dudes let's
see am i out of the way enough
oh no
right in their face
let's just run by them
just run by them
they're so annoying
my back light went out i looked over
like why is it so dark
i forgot it's on a timer here
[Music]
okay back light back on look at that
dude man that makes that makes such a
big difference at least i feel like it
does like having that little bit of
light there in the background
okay let's go ahead and lipindo that
so now we should be able to just
oh that's right she can't jump
dude harry's the only one who can jump
wait what
we actually have to completely break it
okay there we go
it's like i definitely blasted it once
with lupino
oh is this another new spell
all right
[Music]
incendio maybe
got it the repair oh it was actually
rippero
because i saw that uh i saw that big
bridge back there all right let's go
ahead and equip that to
[Music]
let's just do why for now
because chances are we're probably going
to run into some more of those guys oh
and we can use it right here
oh that's pretty awesome
love that
that could be a super useful spell for
puzzles and things
go back
no don't drop
don't drop hermione climb back up
go this way and then let's
there we go push it off
because she's totally not gonna be able
to can't you just climb up right here no
that's what i was afraid of
all right so let's pull it this way then
let go and you're gonna have to climb up
give us enough room turn back around all
right there we go
oh and this one actually broke i didn't
even notice that when we went across
let's there a little bit closer
that's really cool
i like that spell a lot
yeah that could make for some really
nice uh fun gameplay moments
in the future harry potter games like
hogwarts legacy can i drop off right
here okay
i was trying to remind myself like what
this room was again now i remember so we
got to go back let's see drop here
dude what is this over here
it's like a huge door
oh man be awesome if there was something
hidden behind that
i don't really see any way for us to
destroy that we don't have bombarda
if we had bombarda
i bet we could destroy that one
all right let's head this way
and then yeah over there on the right
that bridge has been completely
destroyed
nothing to the left so this is the only
way for us to go
oh now there's some of those dudes that
uh
ron we're gonna need ron because ron's
the only one who has lumos right
oh now it wants me to switch back to
galaxias
that's kind of annoying
wouldn't be so bad if you actually had
like both of them you could equip more
than two spells
the fact that you can only equip two
really kind of restricts you right there
yeah these are the dudes that only ron
could take down
oh no
can i go ahead and grab this though
without ron
nice
that was gonna be super annoying if we
had to wait for ron to open that chest
all right but honestly though what are
we supposed to do right here i think
because i don't think we can can we even
pass through this without ron
no we can't all right so can we go back
and get him now that's the question
oh yeah we should be able to go and hit
that um
we can repair that box now that's right
did you find anything yes i did ron
brilliant now i can climb up here no i
don't want to grab let's climb up
push that button open the door for you
guys
and now all right ron
where are you at buddy time for you to
do your work with uh let's see once
again we gotta go in and change the
spell here
uh there it is lumos
almost duo
why do they call it lumos duo
all right so we got to do that lumos
yeah yeah i know hermione
i've dealt with these guys before trust
me yeah now you guys
i think that makes things much easier
ron can just kind of hold them in place
with the lumo spell
oh no
there we go nice all right that's good
teamwork right there i appreciate that i
appreciate that you guys
don't make me do the uh quick reaction
all right now do i have to shine it
through this
is ron the only way we can get through
here
no
i guess you just you couldn't progress
without harry and uh ron all those
things
i'm wondering the same thing
oh dude this one's got a deal
you know what can i just run by you
i don't think it served the purpose that
the game was uh wanting it to right
there
rosa and i actually thought it was going
to make me go back like specifically
just to uh go through the exit without
being seen and you're friends with folly
okay
i thought it was actually gonna make me
go back and fight that guy
good you probably have to like use
expelliarmus on him or something
oh dude is that dobby
is that a statue of dobby right there
all right so who are we trying to avoid
right here oh this little guy
oh dude there's more uh you know what
i'm gonna switch to hermione because i
bet there's a box over here that we can
apparel
let's go really quick
okay now let's swing it way out wide
like right here
and then run over here yeah this is what
i was trying to get to
a earlier of that now we can climb up
here
give hermione some wigan well potion
which let's see do they share that no
they actually don't so ron has a bunch
and hermione has four now
okay so we got another soldier right
there
so i think i think we can drop right
here and be fine
yeah
all right it's kind of here around here
oh there's a prefect right there i think
we would have been fine i should have
just went
dude can i not like hug the wall like
like you could in the
chamber secret scheme you can't
and go
open the door
friends will follow you nice okay we all
made it through perfect
all right back to this area
go ahead and open this chest up did i
just completely walk by that the other
time
just completely missed that one
all right so do we need to go through
the gate here you've completed the
witch's card set hey let's go hermione's
endurance has increased nice
and i probably should use that wigging
well potion right
because oh no wait hers goes the other
way that is so weird
let's look she's got some red on the far
left side
or maybe that's just showing me that
might just be showing me that it's that
it's increased that it's higher for her
i still want to go and see which
which one we unlock so yeah it was the
witch's card set so we got morgan lafaye
queen maeve
ignacio walt smith beatrix bloxham and
then uh yeah i guess this one was the
new one that we got one-eyed humpback
which famous for develop developing a
cure for dragon pox gun hilda of course
so there she is right there oh yeah
that's the statue that you see in
hogwarts
a couple different areas appears in the
movie as well
alright so let's back out of this area
and let's see do we need to get that
gate open
let's take a look and see what our
objective says probably just escape yeah
i was gonna say it's just gonna say
escape
so let's see should we put a harry in
control here since he's got the map
even though that map really doesn't help
a whole lot
is that area right there i don't think
we're supposed to go there
you know what's crazy though is the fact
that
we still haven't uh made any effort to
find
the potion ingredients that snape asked
us to find i hope that's like a story
point because if not
i'm gonna need i'm definitely gonna need
a reminder to actually like go out and
look for that oh come on get through
there oh i thought i was dead dude can i
go in here
oh this can't be good dude this can't be
good sneaking into the potions classroom
after hours
oh man
i'll take this free chest though let's
see it's gonna be another wizard card
nope
another one of those bits of parchment
that somebody in the comments before
told me what they did
and i completely forgot about them
okay anything else that we can interact
with in here
i don't believe so
all right well i'm glad we came in here
at least so we can get that
i'm just kind of trying to why if it
looks like i'm walking around in a weird
way oh there we go it's because i'm
trying to lock on
the different things and now that i have
hermione
let's see do we want to try and cast
glaciers on that
oh no nothing what about
repair anything
repair is the one that i'm really gonna
have to be on the lookout for like i
wonder if
the only thing you can repair our
bridges and those little boxes or if
there's going to be other things that we
run into at some point in the game that
you can repair
all right nice so we're right back where
we were does that help the exit without
being seen
the marauders map help no they wouldn't
because i know it shows you
the location of those guys but we can
just do that
all right fine we will we will switch
over to harry for this part oh wait dude
is there
man that little blue marker like faked
me out for a second
i was thinking that it was uh another
one of those sentries
all right so are we just supposed to go
back to the common room now
anybody else we're going to run into
hermione you really saved us
oh i just remembered we still haven't
got any grap horn haunted okay so it is
a story element um hermione
oh he got one yes let's go
where did you draco he dropped it huh
ron you're amazing nicely done ron more
than enough for everyone here let's all
turn in i'm worn out and i really could
do with a good sleep
ron's always about to sleep man
all right so i actually think i'm going
to control harry instead of just ending
the day right here
i want to go all the way up because i
want to check in at the uh that bulletin
board
i want to check in on the bulletin board
and and see what our next item is
because it just makes exploration a
little bit more interesting when you're
out and about you can
if you know you're in the area where
there's a missing item you could try and
uh make that
extra effort to go find it so oh
definitely did not mean to go in there
the staircase not being there right away
kind of faked me out
you really should go and see fred and
george sometime hermione
oh yeah we're our friend george in this
game
i can't remember if they're in the same
spot or somewhere
completely different all right let's go
on over
and go to uh sir kadugan
that ladies corridor except for not not
right now because she's not here
odds bodykins
all right and the same to you let us in
all right here we go
let's walk up to this bulletin board
right here and see if you get a wizard
card like you do
oh house points that's right
that's kind of weak i'd rather get a
wizard card lost a remember all last
seen near the stone circle in the
grounds if found please return to this
notice board see that would have been
very helpful if i'd done that before
hagrid's lesson
but i didn't so we'll have to remember
that next time because i think this is
going to be a great spot to end guys as
always thank you all so much for
watching make sure to give this thumbs
up if you enjoyed the video today and as
always
wait i already said that thank you all
so much for watching i'll talk to you
again soon